[Musique]
alex type un pays chaud et ça mon papa
jamais autant de succès avec les filles
courent que tmg pas d'alex mc 1 toi t'es
chez les suricates
c'est là-bas une clope arriver ça existe
ça serait que cette attention parce
qu'ici colombes
ça veut dire que notre copie promet les
vacances
qu'est ce que facebook twitter timber
grinder bon allez là tout le monde se
lave les dents et au lit j'ai dit on va
en boîte alors au programme que ce matin
à cause des partis on secoue peur
c'est qu'on peut trouver de l'herbe à
pinces
[Musique]
qui s'englue ma parole vous est offert
plantaire
ben brik est super et une boîte de
préservatifs sur un panneau monde
[Applaudissements]
tu dois absolument reprendre l'avantagé
avec cette étude venge mec
ça veut dire que tu veux fait pas le
poids je vous paie pour veiller sur une
vacance au sepa de vacances
shi
[Applaudissements]